Did in other news finance ministry has clarified the doubts
raised in some sections of media over financial resolution and
Deposit Insurance that is FRDI 2017 introduced in monsoon session
of
parliament in a statement? I'm going to be said that
the bill is presently under consideration of the joint committee
of parliament the joint committees consulting all the stakeholders on
the provisions of the FRDI bill certain misgivings have been
expressed in the media regarding bailyn provisions of the pill.
The provisions contained in the FR debayle as introducing the
parliament do not modify the present protections to the depth
depositor's adversely at all they provide additional protection to the
deposit arsina more transparent manner.
The Manistee reiterated that FR FR debayle is far more
depositar friendly than many other jurisdictions which provide for statutory
baelyn where constant of the creditors or depositors is not
required for billing. It said that FRD bill does not
propose in any way to limit the scope of power
for the government to extend financing and the resolution support
to the banks including public sector banks statement says the
government's implicit guarantee for public sector banks.
Remains unaffected.